I'm not supposed to say anything but
Chucky's testing you to see if you're
ready to get back together do you think
I have a chance not a good one that is
the way we got to know laura Prepon as a
sarcastic teen on that 70s show and look
at where she ended up in prison but hey
it's a good thing orange is the new
black is a big hit on Netflix and get
this she used to have a weight problem
and now she is telling everybody how she
lost the pounds and she is sharing her
tricks to keeping the weight off there
was so many nights where I would wake up
in the middle tonight like oh my god I
have to be on camera Mauro and I'm so
stressed out how do I lose ten pounds in
eight hours Laura says back when she
first starred on that 70 show she
suffered from bloating and low energy
she began a cycle of crashdïet starved
herself and even injected herself with
hormones to lose pounds she said they
always failed and she would gain the
weight back
it's a stressful place to be in it was
this constant struggle because I love
what I do so much I'm like how am I
gonna figure this out she credits clean
eating with changing her life together
with nutritionist Elizabeth Troy they
created a stash plan a 21-day program
and a book is now a New York Times
bestseller twice a week you have these
easy cooking sessions cook a stash put
it in your fridge and every morning you
build your meals from it that really is
the crux of it you don't have to do this
and the orange is the new black season 3
cliffhanger we last saw Laura's
character Piper and dire straits while
in new photos from the upcoming season
we see her making a run for it and other
pictures Laverne Cox is seen without a
wreath and it looks as if Taylor
Schilling is being tortured by her
fellow inmates and Laura says they're
behind bars look it makes it all very
real
we're stripped of makeup we're all
wearing these same you know khaki
jumpsuits we don't have like a lot of
people get into character by their
wardrobe in those shoes they're her
makeup but everything else and having
that stripped away and having it just be
the moment some moment between my fellow
actresses is unreal it's awesome and
next season is I think it's one of our
best seasons in fact the girls get a new
inmate to Blair Brown the former star of
the days and nights of Molly died she
plays a Martha Stewart type character
who got busted for insider trading